cross 46 between between sectors
officers who
invent new but clearly mercedes is
supportive like vehicles the now
decarbonization of mobility has to
set goals from that's not enough is
always all of these in the sector
but talked about  Of course that has to be possible
uses do you think if you give
priority to economic
regions appeared to me to be a problem I had a car in Untertürkheim a long time ago and I have a
sweden I build my cars is now
mercedes a class when I
travel but how does it look  then off to
pay machines kind of workplace if
not so because easy then that
and of course you can get
in the car so the car some say that
now vodafone is one of our most important
end or apps that is still
familiar and familiar and since he has been looking for neutrals
grown strongly the Fernbus is getting younger
accordingly and then  n the
delivery is also not taken into account so for hard but the mobility turnaround is also one
it maybe one day
retire not only the market the particularly
a combination it is luxury and day
sport then you have to get up
again already part of the solution ok so  if,
despite all the changes, we
don't have fashion and others, especially
in our stock, yes, if
twenty thirty or that set of 20
recognized relatively quickly while my
partner and here in the podcast are very present
maybe a little younger and I want
work for dirty work that
20 20 we do in fact have 20 percent of the
product that is the product is is is the
smallest car to the largest truck
the luxury but how is the communication
i when i hit that when i
want that for one of the most important
i recently saw a statistic
goes or like here at mercedes on solid
looking own swedish brand
in the last ten years very s  tark
is a smartphone on wheels but it's a
very good last assessment even the
trivial one has the feeling build a
cell phone and keep going is it because in the end the energy transition so we have to go through this technical substance but also a lot you look at that it's your focus topic  now
it's not very much a kind of mechanical island it's
actually
my first step in the world making a
30 we'll know much better
that now the main part of the formula 1
german company is responsible
that you keep the toy the way it
is  the partnerships that you
enter into and in the luxury industry and do from time to time or
and in all that time there have been, i think
, for the most part, i say now,
has grown and from our point of view there are
many different partnerships that are
not possible but  with you capgemini
or because you have such an admiration for the
best in the world so neutral
so  living in germany
thinking about the whole chain how come
he also a little quote than as a goal
is unique but is i have
n't achieved it before but
nevertheless is still not there where you
can say formula 1 also euro
in decarbonization
anymore  there is one thing on the internet
that talks about ola källenius the ceo
more than just getting from a to b it's from a
no hints that give me more
feedback and these are now both
who made it who has they
are these kind of testimonials what  is
a thing in the internet of things and
that's the only way with the brand
i feel in germany like a
laxer bahn the german machines and mercedes because we offer the whole
tech company you can say and and
other project maybe a life ttg
understood yes i think that that
a lot of development rebranding
fans are between 15 and 35 years it
seems to me or many say that it will
continue to grow will be
expensive  ste marketing
expenditure minister of economics one understanding most attractive technologies who is then we in the next 20 30 years it's about the products and that's about there
's no way around it we are very fond
of mercedes-benz and we have
to b look at what in a particularly nice way
is really cool
that could be heard where you should be but is
neutral evaluation also better than many
also a luxury company and in both
things and is fully networked of a kind
that probably didn't
trigger it as well as the references to the
second home mean  woman is
busy with shared mobility and
at the very top it is very clear and as i
but europe has mercedes
that you have to do and about but also the
the technology and in fact i have in the
company both mercedes
completely away from the fossil and  Yes,
your focus is very important first of all on the
spectrum, but always with a view to what is
actually hardly
possible  is a fully networked the product and
also profitable in the new so
called after is a thing on the internet of
industries there is often a
talked about luxury about the question how
to that that also belongs to the
a big step and lower
vodafone giga coup a year ago got
the third living space next to home
and wise so the storytelling but also
benz cars will also go there okay but
finance and controlling area
potential in america has potential japan
others nevertheless i have the feeling you
so we're working on that it's not
clear about the paris climate agreement
german let's put it that way i then
i feel to the
almost nothing but automotive company
during my studies with mercedes in
started although in the production i
so-called apple so on sales
you already have
mobility services with companies is motivation in itself
and feel a bit of
pressure  knowledge of modern luxury isn't
so it's something that car manufacturers now
certainly have
if we don't say anything so individual
that doesn't depend on the outside at all so you
this system change and we
invented the car is so that
the desire for the luxury brand  there is
the software is is there was, so to speak, there was the
upper end of the segments where we
put you are but it's
korea australia etc. it's not a transforming
the customer relationship the customer experience
like you say with tesla
traditional formula 1 although i think
that's happening too
that has already been told here more frequently that
contact came and then had the
chance and that in the same company is
only about the product that you now say
things and maybe that committed to over 10
and we have with our
multiple times the turnover that's all
marketing on marketing
two
still that's not something governmental
are not so loud now is
a growing segment but it is not
the handing over of the vehicle all of them
maybe know a special edition
after that a lot of people wanted to drive
one or with a leading position now
alongside work where I do a lot more they
have yes  also the buses from
competes how to switch to
so thinks it’s feasible at all cars
home
countries are represented do you actually know how
to get on then for me that was a
further back they don’t want it
to be like today in the premium
one-dimensional game in the front  göd market
mostly happening now in this
generally not so loud
i have my electric car is
production worked together
normal in this industry quite common
so-called a bit 20 39 said
giga coup quite simply because it
was off your ears because we said it
but a few words  to one
we have set our new goal that I still have positions worldwide now  Since consolidating
the truck
sections have invented this practice as
was then
formula 1 is about a lot
that people say this is a luxury product
emission-free and that's it you have to
when you're I was quite surprised when I was
high the overlap between the
builds is  certainly a very big
transformation in the sense of
probably the most
important thing than just driving but you are also
things that play a very important role
but i wanted to do it as a product and
is that we have to do it differently i
definitely have the replacement and especially for mercedes and that costs  a
dream was there was you were you then a
a simple solution is you get
your strategy but you have to be all markets
part of the group that doesn’t bother me a
luxury area too and
then it has to be fully networked with the
other the podcast with one  clinically
I saw okay that my
future markets for china how often are
you developing  g of the product to now
that we more than ten years ago paris
masters the same logic let's
look like this is what the car looks like and now it
was also important especially for
the look to the left and right
so that especially here in europe there is an
industrial task alongside the
im  have a look and who knows maybe
with a luxury brand so both are there
buyers of mercedes and the user of
maybe so comfortable that we too are
interns or what should i be right now
that is a question
for you tip about you i can for less than a
little more  about that not yes yes and
then try until 2030 at 30 percent
coming now i am so happy here too
strong then in the end depending on the
customer for self-determined individual
will maybe some question marks
because another topic would like to know would like to know
litters can not put anywhere in
comes india one day
thailand the decathlete is a kind of twelve
because the markets most of the marketing
don't know if that  now a kind of
development in itself and especially one it
will have to stay that way for the next 20 years
i thought well like
american market
there you are currently last year
iphones very high i.e. most
fully over the entire value
1 i.e. the turnover is so to speak  larger
manufacturers of such chips for which
the grid will be digital outside is
so that the last question was
ever there due to borders
now at least in sweden in the summer
if you don't get it there will be
an exclamation
point when i compare it to my home
in the so-called
but the core is always innovation and a
different swabian statement but
coworking space at home in the caravan
im always reinventing yourself a lot is
also possible there is a commercial vehicle division
with you can get there you can from finance in
36 and yes this netflix phenomenon i
have  don't make up your own mind after the
turn also be able to decide for yourself
fight  he and you yourself can also be such a
can this that i just want to be the last
guest at ola
källenius to build a car with mercedes
chain want to be co2 neutral and that
vietnam and that's how it was
we are already use cases that i from
as the  stock market value that can yes
like you it from the outside above all things you
mobility so i have my vehicles
all right many thanks i thank this
mercedes driver have so if i
junior group at daimler-benz back then
i can save it now i want to be
jealous of the one who does it  then
the development doesn't change like
mercedes-benz that's learned and
automobile is maybe the
café wherever you are right now has a
per
ola what works well in my
up-and-coming economy then
tesla maybe that that you then
that's the
time that i'm in china  was in february a
bit in older cars so that also
where they spend the money but there is actually a demand for
quality and
precision to stay or  he and one talks out of
my car means smarthome has made
a very very good technical
product and so on so year over
holiday house then immediately has internet
there again and again we are great
about design about the aesthetics both
don’t know how many people don’t
now also gladly accept  that's an
excuse i noticed it and that's
already together yes say it when you're
irritated but nobody knows that everyone
can decide when i want that's
realistic should take a detour
again very briefly on tesla to the
whole issue of gender diversity
yet  screwing is also possible so you're at
home
have met special young people
sometimes from the price
he in stuttgart and have projects
that can definitely head for a large market potential in
2020 and that he's now
reaching milestones of course in
2020 and in fact in the week before
speaking  because this special podcast will be so much
external as well as internal
produced by popstars
is also part of the leadership claim of
claim is doubly difficult who has the
one reason as previously named called
ultimate team sport and has been
about purchasing and the buyer is
someone's doubt mother and
do you look a lot at what apple does
my comfort zone maine [ __ ] is also
happy for you too dangerous or no that
but in the transformation we have
is public the the gentleman this is worth looking at
the bigger picture with quasi out of the socket
but he certainly everyone
who said so I have I have
all-day school childcare and
communicate through which we had
a multiple and in fact we
research in advance is me 1
inspired in the industry
simply because this cube then
but at the same time really
offer a future in the software you can see
vw is there  with Mr. mask off and
done in different divisions and
then again  the
sluggish again itself a brand mercedes benz or
go or in germany i have
is not wrong is a chance we
stay as soon as looked and then there
are a lot of small details is but
huge milestone especially in the area
already it is really super exciting
decided and that  we have now
what you just described what could be
tempting that ok went since i was not
and ever we have always with extremely
year is in fact so that both
noticed you come from a small
i feel good so these
have our financial performance
kinda like the man who has
all the relevant devices via wifi
why now these formula 1 teams more
it's getting more and more difficult there but try it
with
mr or don't try it he
's a current one from your point of view
seen in sweden it's like that  that
a very strong
literally from of  setting but
that this kind of block formation
came into play relatively
quickly as under is on the road together
build your own
significantly increased here in the last
then you will get that right and
parents in Sweden usually see
autonomous driving shortly before Christmas
which makes a whole  where if you then
individual mobility that we
now have so there are the
developers and so i'm on them I
don't want to speculate about that we
decided more because with them
almost all men are on parental
leave and so the most valuable success
really comes from the business itself  from
strong partners in the suppliers
mechanical one would manage a
few years under stock price is also
valuation probably says that's right that's
worth it we have supplied with our street
town in sweden called
västervik that as said is
about sharing and now seats  I
car shop to the car shop and you
rfte that with you too spokeswoman no
what you what you do with a car
maybe a particularly in the last
digital infrastructure on in our
working I also see that the
world has somehow reached with google and and
to have the first certification of
aesthetic soul and one
is in front of the world is for you
quarantine rules that
just go back and let's see
but if you open a car today
technical side step by step
everyone is therefore firmly in the mood and
take it a lot more  women are actually allowed
into the team
and i know someone else who is
here and speaks for mercedes-benz and
already so that at least in the last
few years i can sometimes experience such an
inspiration in the
two years in the pandemic
and then this thing on the internet
like this quite rightly so much
the business itself sometimes when
facebook and amazon and then  there are
different countries, i went
over and i did,
fortunately, go up
we also in those in the
understanding to have what is
technically we don't do but we put an
amazing number of cars on again for years
even if you don't have a car or
cars when we have our own was
simply not practicable but
different cultures so it is
a so-called level 3 system and
post ag positive result written
comes as actually i know them
then they are all computers and i
business customers is at vodafone who
participate in the project  where we the
transformation will be our
but not as much as we would have
how important it is this privacy
value we want to go there too or say
rule of thumb of of of total content
at the same time there is a neighbor here
software stack of proprietary
we own the if we the  four
elements we often focus on mercedes and
desig  n expert then you
don't say personally but i'm
demographic and and the fan base
management positions are as in the
world with alibaba and different
just goes to vodafone.de giga coup
- and how you can do that in a
not quite
fit and yourself  you decide well
that's very high when you've
grown up with this person you know
if things have to be networked the business model must
be similar to one of those
otherwise it would be a market where you
can develop a bit yourself several times so
start-ups came to me at all
somehow everything is right yes that the
first real full scale car factory
has the financials of formula 1
that we see talking on the one hand supply
if you go from level 2 to level 3
germany slows down
in stuttgart that is a daimler truck
after many years both in production
to be able to go upstairs if the forest has
you a bit so
i mean stephan sloot stefan edberg
to be able to if i from a  after b want so
mean it was like that for decades there was
try now not the strategy of
basic understanding like how hopes like something like that
software is but the software stack of the
chain we have all our
but maybe because
we only manage half was already
strongly growing clientele  many
teams since wars are producing better
global leading companies in
the now full of the film
and that also ended up in development
a car is maybe around 70
chinese platform is so what is in the
is that is that is perfect and also the
lives of our customers and  customers therefore
stop by in the year not only
because there are almost situations where
beautiful design translates to which
luxury mobile phone manufacturers that have been built
outside of Germany
well
development works only rudimentarily
suppliers said we want to follow up with
another and since
business is now before the 23rd  at a giga
improved dramatically ü  About the
quasi-established companies and
mobility and individual individual
commercial vehicle area this image have
soy 1 1 a car company and a brand
mobility services yes growing
is not like an island and only speaks
sex i am fully with you is too low
percent  you buy from suppliers and 30
do that's what it's all about and then you have
young fans and when you're
mobility because it's also mobility and
that was the first vw m class back then
the conditions in sweden are a bit
the biggest and most important market is
actually that  the car drives itself and
is there yes the staff changes to the
results so there are so many studies
when you drive the car so next
to at school if i press now because
years for the participants in the end the
business is a complementary business
role plays the  formula 1
is also made because on the
one hand it's a beautiful
but also because it  a very high
little new and now all of
a sudden you've got it right that's a top tennis player
at the latest 20 39 be co2 neutral if
with yourself he also has to
bridge percent is your own added value
different platforms in china other
other side so rarely have okay
mobility in mind  everything and also the top
and now it's up to
us like last year where it's up to
the say if you really
we are growing so closely together with mercedes-benz from
software back then
but our main focus is on private things
like mercedes is after  as before very
coup fetch with suitable tariff of
customer groups is so different
going to belong yes i have
high quality physical product but
high tech screens it is embedded in
also responsible and that is a
friendly for for young family with
called and we have that in tuscaloosa
or was was a world-class player
whole formula 1 team also because of that
now publishing house  If the suppliers get
the feeling that diving gives a lot of new
innovation speed was more many
last races something that I
build last to all the ecosystems that we
in the USA and so on and so on and too
technically shaped water even meant
different of the men with
okay that  that means there you come a little okay
basic programmed i have
implemented our strategy a little bit consistently
maybe conceivable that one day
are and that every company
you with us until then in the business
segment of individual mobility
will also get an extra 120 gigabytes
amazing because you think so  could be
very, very big difference of course
kind of living room filled with italian
motor sport marx born so
you also have an ecosystem the profile
cars start ups or more mature company already
visa blocks watch the chinese programmed similar to
pascal but i have that
and individual mobility that’s
different  background  nd
also has development board so before
that you have to
know technological partners there etc from the smartphone world so here
okay there is another company in the market
round of the last race fighting
alabama built what demand for it because
and no I don’t know him but we
in which on the way to the full
that for the young people it is not at all
technologically but also in terms of the
landscape more and more too high-tech
exactly to your own customer group
normally you have a stronger
younger generation in planning or already there ok have
quite integration and
current task insofar you have
to forget everything again i will since
data volume is
an absolute growth business yes
from our customers with with with a
first mercedes was a racing car the
business model the main business of the
best pilots in the world
want to stay against each other then you have to act along the way
and say we have our
designer furniture and you have the feeling
that there is a better theme and
you like it because that has
a we have to hope that the product
liability pandemic was so good for us that we
man I’m also doing projects in
younger companies is that you can  so
we are our architects
ourselves you actually have to develop a generation
of formation spence okay one thing
that you might take a close look at so the
business result out to diversity is
now loads with then have to develop
interfaces that is really in
electrification the digital vehicle
components so high-performance  chips
climate moderately very negative trend some of
your own products here and you have your
mr. jelinek that ordered his
at some point then he too
but that is essentially also a
yes very technically logically
is the largest branch if you now
sit so-called mercedes with di the
do you think then normal is specifically
a few years older d  as is true but
maximum entrepreneurial potential in
observing or that is then these are
so i mean a hollywood script would be
us going and the vast majority to
stuttgart but i am with that
i would have to go back to school okay you have
a small moon landing now builds
from the  start ups which you clean yourselves
wow that's just nice and also in the
sense of the customer it works well and in
terms of sales and also earning potential
right there you have to look a
bit into the company's structures
subsidiary was the mercedes
past and that you have to do something
now  be precise here i am
and of course our motto luxury profile
me there so when i researched
two technical trends so we created
the man there in education are in
demand in our case for luxury cars and premium that the cake project, so to speak, moved
to the usa  and one
is very important for
mercedes benz what diversity model selection and brands
also in a cloud structure that means
digital soul in the car but have one
and politically at the end that politics
work that i have over the years
still have enough understanding to
yes hadn’t been better here
look at all worldwide so that’s very
very important here formula 1  like mercedes
wanted to go to nice and race and
also about this new group
you more the poppy in the moon settlement but
small computer in the car but
yes a change in drive technology
yes only born away but only a year closer
structures education
system maybe only than tesla so
or  especially the part in tesla of
our suppliers has already
done that, you have to be curious and you have to
drive the horse confidently and also
talk to people about it to further strengthen the freedom
to travel, that said
, and if we
surpass that well, we even
know you  we ensure
child care and so on around there are
so many excited  now coming
up to electromobility
said okay i don't care what
it doesn't have a new topic what's up to
date that's so fair that
you signed up from the tax
area and of course it's
possible when will what be finished why
could want  it concerns my first real job
and so on for the product
kind of freeze open software mindset that
in general has been known to be
also very focused on the mercedes
also willing to learn new things
low noise level all these
but also this digitization and of
course that too  the software that
wenz
fantasy one would have
to live there one then I actually found a
lot that she also
for then ordered that from daimler the
customer would like I just want
to implement your identity also finds the
way in here in the next few years  am
different materials, etc., where it has come from rather
the last few years,
something that the  since mere
eyes can make it possible for both parents to
develop it's also the case
that I finished on time and so were
then called at daimler and there I personally
I don't believe that the
market capitalization in this business has
this rating by the country  and so
maybe you can't
tear each not so much the last two
CO2 neutral future and quickly
so up to the race there from time to time
once more grew up
things come more come together so
customers in the case private use case yes
heard there want  but we ourselves partly withdrew the
amount of computing power in the
vehicles, so
I used to be very sure that we were
also so successful in that, we have gained
psychological reasons here
in this phase, which
must be difficult to develop a judgement
but is also, for example, in the
but a topic with
which we also work to some extent adequately
can and still have
the car so if i lived a strong in my
from 95 to 99 and gasser have a
different structure and want it
and then god said then
clearly i taxi driver in germany
at least the people at that time also have to
stick inside that is  not at the
end of two or three machines,
the customer can also go in and out
calculation for every vibration in
aesthetics meets technology
that means i don't always have to be in the
architect so will be if
certainly for at least two
i'm sitting in slow-moving traffic
or watching each other  then have new players
what is important what works and what doesn't
i try to look
around fashion full of what can move what do you think
and we've just introduced the new one of
our own chinese manufacturers
mercedes taxi that's
years now we've also seen
intense competition  so an industry
i cool mercedes great name now
that you get sensible  g the family also
have to make the vehicle themselves you have
to say yes the steel industry and so on yes that of
course now looks the
will for that the customer wishes are
first clear says the car says hello ola
completely comfortable and completely problem-free in
what you said or at least that was part of
the world  happened
decades if no longer deal
somehow see ahead we have
youth center hanging out together
maybe can do with
it and then just dialogue with the
apparently no longer so and i have
this software in the software strong
you fear the market the most so
any person who you  particularly
works
meets design lines and and and and
lets say the whole cake is
i was lucky earlier in my
stuck in a traffic jam on the autobahn i can tell my
what can sweden do better than
maybe they
understand what is important what makes
engines  or powertrain regulations
must pass that's a
is ecological  ch saves costs is better
can manage together you are then
in transformation from
the worlds that you know from the
financial market a bit like we founded
the thesis was me that
now it will also be like
the bears and that’s where you want something special
brought to the front because if you so
surprised me because i thought it
sonia how should i say that is the
källenius the horse in the right
germany
engineering teams discuss it
from the sgg mentioned a few points is
entry barriers for the established
but it says you are  now also well-
established well-known players who you
career here at mercedes four years in
at least until now no restrictions
activate drive pilots and then
actually always wars the first meeting
just discussed well
we definitely not overrated
cross-industry topic we want
smartphone ecosystem you think  you just
passed there no more electric
that  the market valuation of mercedes
backgrounds fan of the rate or
to we will start with what
we really this this the focus on
in the luxury segment from let's say
a mercedes to a mercedes how is
initially the probability was
there
brain or the central heating system
position  the temperature is exactly the
product name that's how we are you could say you
always have the mercedes and they are
always struggling to find the best solution
technologies that are no longer there and are
just moving in but new ones are also being added
that the established ones we also have
business closed so to speak in the end  will
we spend an incredible amount of time will
know swede how was your path after working
in our further development
of formula 1 and that was
it is up to us the distribution to
from the car you have to know for yourself that
i really mean the greatest gift of all
radio stations that
limousine is really you learn that
against the background that  he himself says
our own production our own
then also fuel the 100% either
have done here is
first skeptical about such a
is productive even if sometimes one
did not agree with the
new one too and when you sum up all
i'm just trying it as an established
yes now not very high there was one
this sovereign almost sliding
and we are all at mercedes can already
differentiate he in the
that motorsport brand was born today
is thinking about how it looks in
quota
control wars back in the  phase then
somehow the models from apple and
from tesla that is extremely appreciated the
product as someone who knows
our position in china but of course
pure fascination so you make
operations co2 neutral the
trucks together what you want
means we have to have both the  usually
we want to control
a very large part of the disk for a reason  ussion is
germany
we have often discussed that and
higher is preset and from tours
to be postponed
five years in our favor so a car
market capitalization looks inclusive
promote something that is particularly
synthetic or biological
driving behavior on the road at all
mercedes are already so similar
in  fact as a child i
indulged in taxi rides in digital infrastructure and now thought
video conference marathon from morning to
had been obvious for two years now, so to speak
, what was
decisive for you this project
suspect have under control as well as
passion to the profession
why we have
become  then it would also
look like the car drives alone and i have time
so we'll manage this mix between 1 1 digital
this year but
yes there are already the big ones that have been
developed which means that a
strong manufacturer is not worth it
ok ok  probably
development process  s usually three
people who love technology yes what is in the end for
sometimes it's also an emotional one
it the first is love in the world it's
the new player and there's a
there isn't amazon facebook now and in
the end people don't really believe
me me  at the beginning, touchpoint says is
strong, our software is
produced,
but if i'm not there in the
evenings it can also be tiring it's
germany lived for a year and a half
pioneering work we have a completely
from apple maybe obvious with
discussion
women in the  management levels so how
to speculate too much who is coming or
for me maybe i would like to short
four five years than you always have to
watch what the new ones are doing but one thing is
platforms
pretty big cake now it applies to
CEO and since then the
share of it has increased with gold  standard of
outside of düsseldorf because my father had
his own car at marc
zumbrunn luxury vehicle  to
reduce the cycle we all
are so important you have to show the car
you more important the product the car
believe in established manufacturers
new car in a segment where mercedes
area to expand yes there we do
my my message is
clear to me
google are then alibaba  baidu i assume so
i would
get nothing today you have to make your own
statements from
i am a friend of set goals i.e. doubled my
footprint in a very nice
course
i have already done business there i have
many female executives
we have them  distribution of this bad
apple squad there are also rumors and
it is very very important
to build what innovative
claim that would actually mean
I'm sure I'll be there on the television and
we're looking forward to a world that was
n't represented before we have one
ourselves  or the communication for this is
cutting-edge technology at the absolute
highest level  thinking about the future so we
like to think that now you have to rush ahead
no concrete statement about tesla
don't you click a startup bonus
and so on then you work with the
congratulations amazing performance but
physical mapping yes there is already
check smartphone or I would like to
touchpoint have these been
in an industry like the car industry is
currently a vertical integration that
we have internally like i'm just looking
left and right what did he do
mobile phones world with the platforms
setting what
capitalization cake something to
market valuation  but get co2 from her
the entire co2 footprint of our
already had a relation at the age of 89
then also stands with the dead was about
we can see our look new and what is
happening but not with the
completely new work built you have new
you have to invest maxi  in the
but one thinks first of all he is there
he is anyway always  not there yet
chinese tech company for
just leaning back a bit and
have all these things come to that
do you have more detailed information one described such a
have set goals before
where such a lab about new things
or what is he doing there going crazy
yes one  luxury product it has to be accordingly
there are still certain models that
at least for a certain time
maybe a very short demand
similarities with the business model
felt like you actually heard or
rest or move with passenger
passenger in our favor
but then came later about my
studies we do  more and also things the
assumption i really do
n't know you have to be able to talk but for us in the
then also be noticed and you
because they at least have their trucks because
you have to get in touch with your own DNA of the company
what's up he needs
travel intensity that we had  in front of the
customers there together because it
is clear that you have to m  ow learning was
mainly male dominated there was
somehow a kind of quota and for
production production system built
in a conglomerate one speaks of
new technologies and at the same time then
has a long tradition has to
test one but also stands
for we develop taxis and yes that is
from apple  would also have the art on
so i'm totally there that they
could also argue the product
technologically and what does
formula 1 teams mean then such a sport you can do
about internships and then maybe later
the suppliers for
but if a bank is in
and also develop ideas yourself, which is
necessary, even if the end goal
is to keep it in there, it's why
I'm not entirely convinced and speak soy certain industrial infrastructure the pandemic I'm not entirely convinced
Autonomous driving is
certainly not a smart
vehicle for me, we have our
own there  there are a lot of
ecosystems, they are the people  hen there
save supervisory board members then there is
so you felt like a
the well-known
end of the mass market for those
noticed afterwards because they also made a lot of
us but we don't have to
swarm intelligence of the market has
a so-called conglomerate discount
canon what mercedes benz stands for  what is
fascination is is the is the most
exciting we've had before it's almost
advice on strategy during the
for the design that's a very very
very strong in germany and some
tell us what in china is
much more aggressive so internet meme
transformation or even  disruption
car manufacturers who all use similar good
so it always comes from a
pioneer in this m class project in
only in the future if you also recognize
a quota and there is also a new
infrastructure must first be rebuilt
are currently technically important
millions of products  for sale and
exchange study in switzerland
markenver  talking about mercedes then in
our brand promise how do we make it
15 years ago we set a goal back then whether
digital architecture is very important they do
everything here too it is quite
and it is right when we announced
the technologies that really make the car
the place is of course that the
european  brands but it is not our
regulations for the board of directors and i think the
customer's point of view is an offended
question that's something you know about the
races but at least he gets
built-in great cars produce
hardware or software both you
have and will have a sustainability strategy
and then he thinks  financial market
almost with the truck and that
shows the order of magnitude sales of the china
automobile company a winning business
motor sport in the world with all these
important the
energy source the original energy source
germany in st gallen and has
the future focus
on having a stomach like someone
heh  upt business so mercedes benz luxury
active process so that you then
have that we take the picture from
now he will revolutionize it in the
a bit from part of the storytelling
the usa and especially in such a project
sure that we our customers in
the last decades we new
customer interface is between us
now you've been so many years in
it was now 2007 or 2008 we have
a bit of live commentary from more
my god that's a huge task is
innovation from strong partners to
that we have for formula 1 remains
legends and  also the legends of the
so then you could maybe even
you have now taken out as explained
if you if you have no goals at all
we have another question about the between
must be fossil free your own car
and one
for mercedes is the
next two years  still there we are investing
and egg brand that is a kind of first
technologies knockout  mmen and the
industry daimler and then also carried out
sold very few good
ones, so leading a better future, so to speak, we
think that communication is important
and the customer and what the prices are
relevant what do you think is often what you think in the end was
often not too many people are
included then  to the german language and
had to console us a bit
profitable business and we will find the
right zeitgeist for the
germany and works is also for
benefit couples with our technical work
but you will see it
differently one would say it
runs because the difference if i  look
massive there is much more to
come luxury world i have me there is
me yours too but it is a task that we
this mixture of a high margin
and the share is on average around 10
present so pays for both 1 both
looked at the  on the top levels
is just in such a
third of the under the foreign country v
to build you mercedes that's a decathlon so it's the electric car
and then the car
there you might
get us very strong on your own strategy
but more important for you digitized
to germany a fascinating country
one of the most important german
mercedes benz was already here my
burden of that  podcast that was there before the election
in the last song finale then
very consistently approach this bonus
modern luxury in every era that is
computer band if you if you the first
nevertheless a lot of sales
with good voters my experience tells you
what strategy our colleagues and
upheaval phase  then there are also new ones,
so the so-called executives
have increased disproportionately much responsibility and
percentage so it has
and must prove that mercedes have given a
company what such a side
can do with the tyler brulé
so still in germany how much
is also very important heard brand
on our image but also on our
know h  ow and then the best of it
is not just a sport that you
and this brand promise he
always believed in the next few years
calls company it goes back
to the red bull just ahead so
in use that also means electricity
or decarbonization both it's
mercedes chaos then  do you have the feeling
our claim meanwhile you can
what has always interested me and because
covetousness and exclusivity
you are at least listed in the dax in
true that china as good as we are
who managed the project
here you start anew then you get
Colleagues at daimler trucks then have
executives from department
heads to absolutely shot molecule founders and
players and there are definitely
due to the racing commissioners have to
master but you have
to make products for the customers so
i've arrived that's what
our founding fathers gottlieb  daimler and
as mercedes knows the customer can choose the
order of magnitude  ng we will experience that
stuttgart at home but you are and
but it is right
now to meet again and then also new to
the father also works in the automotive sector
very strong technology tradition
successful player in the business
which is then filled up later he has to
understand or just  was is now -
maybe 35 percent or 35 to 40
startups that are either in the
author for a luxury brand that's
clear it's also a way direction way and made
decisions so even though that's
really possible then mastering all sports
so clearly that was one
not an either or it's then
up to the board of directors what's the percentage
not but you have to make the change yourself
special
carl benz they have yes is that at all
that you don't have you there
now i think the question
no ok then you are right  but you
invent relatively and you look at the
customer knowing that mercedes benz is he
hotel industry have established themselves or
will remain for almost three years
there is potential for the mercedes share
was also a bit namely consolation
stay on at that time heavy i until i
could have you could have imagined
so we will already have products in which will also be green there we are converting it
now it is  that doesn't differ
so it happened that you exchanged
ideas with both and both of these topics
first automobile invented and there it says
from the inside looks and what
huge chance something different than if i
design you also have to be your own
partnerships were always important and
balanced and  to the olympic
quick to st gallen so after actually looking at the
female
car industry and there a
lot of the strategy applies to cars we have
and there of course there is also a
question how can it actually be
donating has to be he there was me
or she  in good hands such a 1 1 1 1
that formula 1 has developed so
test tracks that i'm now a
designer  is completely different industries from
certainly here in europe with mercedes with
am and will remain difficult in the
long run and studying also directly to then daimler
segment hold but it never was and is
percent but it is also the case that china
executives and in the year we
will  the decisive factor for the
cinebench mark was what they
actually do live and of course
normal road traffic, so to speak, the
pyramid starts at the top with the
train compartment is his it's
innovation pioneering spirit in the foreground
so there are then no longer typical ones of
course there is the financial market
that you are with  winning a hallmark from the
gold medal so to say
that you are so relevant and listening now
for a brand like mercedes
that also started to stay important to know
when it was 2008
george that we know when when when you
came right i am then  with
other technological and so on but
is worldwide by a large margin the
now sc  hon electric trucks or the
future and also how to have a future
maybe just another area here
not so we'll come capital
car engineer or designer
then we didn't have during the
race today either and
so the teams grabbed a billion value
the whole package has to be right now it
's almost 30 years now that i can use
first-class maybe such a
g yes as i said being at mercedes s
innovative top but
and stuttgart would have started ok and
always look what are the
star works and it manages that  that's
a bit unsure what's going to be
financed at first we have to have our own
i have to say i'll stay
positioned as a brand and
they're actually your view of all of this
that was a few years old
who came into contact pretty much the
biggest market then followed  from usa as
we in fact at 8 percent you ca
n't sell the main business like
au  ch always fashion designer the table
what i do buy it and then you get it
very very important your own dna too
class is nico sometimes want it is
no longer we say they were allowed to work
at mercedes was i
happen here in the transformation  who,
so to speak, stands for absolute luxury and
emotionallyabsolutelydevastatedbutshould
at the same time be impressed by this promise of luxury
how will the company
remember beautiful exclusive luxury I said we have to
technical limits what can you do now
anyway is then the probability of
producing cash flows by enormous
we but  in a fundamental
one is yes now we are talking about formula
class and e commerce is already going into
let's say new mobility
customers also demand both of course
and also talk about it because with that yes and
electric trucks on the road
also twice as difficult or twice
as much mercedes with george  then measure how much
comes out as a winner who stays
ma  chen the
attitude of the swabian up to 2020 every year a percent was
set up a global company
individual market or
keep europe it is already so
transformation of the car industry and
how do you get that then i would have
difficult to get long waiting times
want the whole digital  use
certain situations then it will not
combine what we have with high-tech
at the same time it also has to
work on buses for the long haul
to make investments for which,
however, almost half of them are abroad to become
small boss for profit
1 teams also as well as sports franchises  do it
at times what such a
digital ecosystem mercedes but with
initiatives that you also do so
stand and our task is to
do you really succeed with these
great products you have to see it that way an
engineer doesn’t rest on your laurels
now there are two disciplines that
fueled it  will and about compensation buy
transfo  rmation so of
course you play together, of course, the us market is also
cooperation projects and you say that there are
cases, it’s all about convenience
and that’s the great thing about having one
on top of any delivery vehicle
if you do a bit of research about
luxury to keep communicating what
and we think it's unique that's why it's
black and white that
as soon as you've invented something you always look at something
the semitrailer truck
my feeling because you're man
prove that mercedes isn't just
a key topic for you today the super nice entry-level models of
something in the usa  what I dallas cowboys
one is electromobility that his name is the one
in the dernau group should be very big to you that's
why it's important everyone
you get inspiration you can say
I grew up in Sweden back then companies
like mercedes don't
wisely offer any other game than maybe
bridges to the  major platforms and
communication et  cetera, like here,
we then turn on green electricity
and they say that's not it
, mercedes is very good for the future push a
button and suddenly everything will be
full because the decisive factors are
the numbers so business administration salespeople but
only technologically fascinating tasks electric
drive isthesecondsoftware
fuel cell technology issuch
a winner but
also flee tomorrow or are
there either volvo families or
definitely more so let's say yes than
there are football teams occupied by me
but do you think that it will be
autonomous but we will gradually have
a new player coming  at the end of these
differentthesoftwareproductam
use cases de man from there the world
autonomous driving you can at least hear it said
after the transformation
manchester united is working on it and the fan base is
not just an engineer so say now
but also global
familiesandwho knows whowasavolvofamily
whatdidyouseethisconcern
would be at all possibleforsuchanapple
development see that this phase
someone who himself the gate on board the
stent system autonomous almost because they
are getting better and better more and
more driving situations that maybe that
cars park themselves such
topics and step by step with  even
more computing power in the vehicles
very intelligent the algorithms we are
developing even better sensor technology sensors
that can look further more precisely then
also see what is happening in traffic
i really see a
rapid development here in this in
this decade at the end it is  Yes, everything was
a topic that also had something to do with these chips, i.e. what
you need for them
is that, I think, if you interrupt it a bit from the
outside in on the
automotive industry
, what role they have,
how strong are you in the end, yes, you can hear it
now  but again dependence on the
manufacturers of so microchips in the end
te  the raw material to be able to build
on that is now
worrying a modern high-tech first class has
thousands of individual semiconductors in the
motto there is one because there are mostly
sophisticated products technically what
is in the world and we
work very, very deeply with it
Chip manufacturers and together and the
development has been very steep in the last
few years and it
's going up, which means that you
have more
computing power that you can fit in a car
, significantly more than in
the past, this computing
power meets intelligent
algorithms  artificial intelligence and on
sensors i would say eyes and
ears that the car can see much
better and the combination of these
enables things that we
could not do at all before
and the product becomes safer that also becomes
more pleasant and of course not
only the topic  autonomous driving but
also the connected can s  If I then
promote the car, you open up
a digital world where you can do a lot more with these
fantastic screens that we
now have in the cars heike
screen dqs,
including something like watching a film and
so on and so forth  that is
[music]
[applause]
[music  ]
[music]